what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
8 discussion video this video is gonna
be a little bit different than what I
usually do I want to talk about the
crypts of Winterfell because this has
always been one aspect of the story that
fascinates me but I am not necessarily
going to be predicting anything myself
because I have already done that in a
previous video about this subject what I
want to do is discuss some other very
interesting things about the crypts and
I want to see what all of you have to
say about these things personally I have
always felt that the crypts of
Winterfell would come into play in terms
of the end game but with only six
episodes left in the television show I'm
not exactly sure what they can do at
this point I can obviously make a few
guesses but I would rather discuss
several of the potential scenarios the
show could go with then I want to see
what all of you think is most likely to
happen there are some really cool
theories out there about the crypts of
Winterfell but I think most of them are
pertaining to the books but even though
there is only six episodes left I still
feel like the crypts can be useful when
telling the ending of this story in the
TV series at the very least there could
be something really cool down in those
crypts but if they're gonna take us back
down there one last time what purpose
can it serve now when season 8 begins we
are finally gonna have all of the Starks
back in Winterfell for the very first
time since season 1 but not only will
all of the remaining Starks be there but
so will Daenerys and her dragons and if
there is one thing we all know about the
dragons is they seem to make magic a
hell of a lot stronger so there is no
telling what kind of crazy [ __ ] could
awaken down there on those crypts if
anything at all
Winterfell would Sailfish shrouded a
mystery but the crypts that lie beneath
the castle are even more mysterious and
all of the Starks have this strange
connection with them in george RR martin
has left all these breadcrumbs
throughout the books that let us know
this is a very special place for the
Starks and it's not just because this is
where they keep their loved ones after
they have passed there is a much bigger
secret down there just waiting to be
revealed
which I believe George will do in one of
the last books but I am really curious
if whether or not we will get a taste of
this in the final season
would be the perfect time to do this in
my opinion considering everyone will be
there together I am pretty confident we
will get at least one more scene down
there but maybe even more when John
arrives in Winterfell he's gonna learn
about his true parents from bran and
knowing John he's gonna want to return
to the crypts to see his mother Leona
and he will probably go down there and
see Ned again - and just think about how
he had kept us a secret this entire time
to protect him but if you have not read
the books then you might not know this
but John has always had this very strong
connection with the crypts John used to
have dreams about them all the time and
John had dreamt that he was wandering
the empty Castle searching for his
father while descending into the crypts
only this time the dream had gone
further than before in the dark he'd
heard the scrape of stone on stone and
when he turned he saw that the vaults
were opening one after another as the
dead Kings came stumbling from their
cold black graves now that is a very
creepy dream to have and it must have
some meaning to it
John had another dream that he was down
there but this time he was limping past
the stone King's on their Thrones their
gray granite eyes turned to follow him
as he passed and their gray fingers
tightened on the hills of the rusted
swords upon their laps John could hear
the dead Kings telling him that he is
not a stark and they would tell him
there is no place for him in the crypts
he should go away but something is
calling to John down there there are
many levels within the crypts and the
one that interests me the most is the
lowest level of them all there is a
section of the crypts that is in
complete darkness and it's partially
collapsed I have always felt like
something might be in there and it could
be the thing that has been calling to
John all of these years personally I
always associated these dreams with
Jon's lineage or parents I should say
when John would have dreams of being
down there in the dead kings of winter
telling him he doesn't belong there and
that he's not a stark this may have been
telling us the truth about John the dead
kings of winter were right which we
found out these last two seasons of the
show John is not a stark but he's a
legitimate Targaryen and the crypts of
Winterfell are meant for Starks only but
not all Starks technically speaking
lyanna stark's should not have been down
there but Ned did in anyway and there
are several theories revolving around
Leon a statue that is down there and it
could come into play during the final
season some people say there might be
some kind of artifact or proof about jon
snow's lineage inside of leona statue
some say Ned may have put ray gars harp
inside of her statue while others say
Sir Arthur Dayne sword Don might be
inside there as well which could end up
being Lightbringer considering it is
already a very special sword that is
said to have been made out of a fallen
star which both form house Dayne sigil
Ned said he returned to sword to star
fall but Sir Arthur Dayne sister ashara
dayne
allegedly committed suicide shortly
after this and heard that body in the
sword hasn't been seen since so who
knows there is no telling what Ned may
have taken from the Tower of joy and put
inside of Leon a statue in the crypts I
did believe there was something inside
of her statue but now I have to ask
myself are they really gonna do this at
this point does Jon need to find
something down there to believe the
truth about his parents because I don't
see why Jon wouldn't believe Bryan when
he tells him what he saw during his
flashback plus I'm sure Sam will confirm
this by showing Jon the journal that was
kept about Rey Gore's annulment and his
new marriage but let me ask all of you
this do you believe there is something
inside of leiana's statue waiting for
Jon and if so what do you think it is if
there isn't anything inside of her
statue then do you believe there is
something in the crypts at all waiting
for Jon to find it
perhaps in the lowest level of the
crypts that are partially collapsed I do
think there is a very strong possibility
something is down there some people also
believe there might be a dragon or
dragon eggs under Winterfell one of the
main reasons people believe this theory
is because there was once a dragon in
Winterfell many years ago when the pact
of Ice and Fire was established this was
an alliance made between houses Stark
and Targaryen during the dance of
dragons at the time Prince Jack Ahri's
of Dragonstone flew on his dragon vert
max to Winterfell to meet with Creegan
stark and while he was there many people
believed vormax may have laid eggs
within the crypts of Winterfell even
some of the small folk of the north have
been known to say that the hot poles are
he
by a dragon living under the castle
personally I kind of find it hard to
believe a dragon is living under there
because it would have to come out and
eat at some time and people would notice
a dragon flying around what their fellow
eventually but dragon eggs being down
there is a little bit more plausible but
still a bit of a stretch but I have
always found it very interesting that
Winterfell was built over natural hot
springs the water is piped through the
walls and chambers to heat them which
makes Winterfell a hell of a lot more
bearable in the wintertime it's genius
for many reasons but could there be a
deeper meaning to this perhaps a bigger
purpose bran the Builder is the one who
built Winterfell anni also built the
wall I think there might be a specific
reason why he chose this exact location
to build crypts deep into the ground
there is another theory that I want to
talk about because I find this one very
intriguing in this theory kind of
influenced my theory about why I think
the Great War will end and Winterfell
ever since I started to talk about the
night king being defeated in Winterfell
many of you have asked me about the dead
kings of winter having any kind of role
in this well there is a theory that
states the crypts of Winterfell are
actually a prison that bran the Builder
had built to contain the great other or
more specifically the night King this is
more of a book theory because in the
books george RR martin has more or less
stated that the night's king we know
today isn't the same night's king that
was the 13th Lord Commander of the
Nights Watch which means there has been
more than one night's king over the
centuries most of you already know why I
believe the Starks castle was called
Winterfell I think this is where the
king of winter or the god of winter
literally fell from power the name of
the castle was kind of a reminder that
this is where the night King had been
defeated before this is where the king
of winter for many generations ago had
fell but over time the meaning of the
name Winterfell had been forgotten
another interesting way to look at this
is why are the older Starks in the
crypts called the kings of winter could
it be because they are the ones that
were needed to defeat the night king the
person who brings the storm and the long
night unless some of those kings of
winter and the crypts are all former
Knights Kings that were defeated and
locked up down there this is why the
Starks were always warning people that
went away
coming these words lost their true
meaning over time just like the name of
their castle Winterfell lost the meaning
of its name over time but it all relates
to the night King and like I have said
before this is why a stark must always
remain in Winterfell they are the only
ones who hold the true power over the
others what is very interesting though
is when Winterfell was actually built
bran the Builder constructed the castle
when it scripts right after the others
were defeated legend says that Brandon
the Builder razed Winterfell after the
generation long winter known as the long
night that could be a clue as to why
Brennan the Builder made the crips of
Winterfell right after the long night
had ended this cavernous vault which is
longer than Winterfell itself has
several levels to it with vaults even
deeper and darker where the older kings
were buried and don't forget about the
section that is partially collapsed
where no one has been that could be the
location of the night's king that was
defeated during the long night that
could be where the original king of
winter resides and this may be why
Brandon the Builder decided to build
this over the natural hot springs that
does sound like a good place to keep the
gods of winter in prison for eternity
but you know what's even crazier
even though Winterfell was built over
natural hot springs that the crypts are
always still very cold when Ned takes
Robert down here to see Leona the book
references how Robert was shivering in
the subterranean chill because it was
always cold down there if you have
something basically made of ice locked
up down there then it could explain why
it's always so cold down there but there
was also something Ned Stark used to
dream about that could be another clue
as to what's really going on while Ned
was in King's Landing he dreams of the
crypts of Winterfell and he envisions
the kings of winter watching him with
eyes of ice those last three words
always jumped out at me when Nets all
the kings of winter and his dreams they
had eyes of ice there was only one other
thing that comes to my mind when I think
of eyes of ice and that's the great
other I'm sure this theory probably
sounds very wacky to some of you but it
really makes a lot of sense to me
they might not go in this direction in
the show but for the books it seems very
plausible there are way too many
connections between the Starks and
Winterfell and brain in the Builder and
the night
King or nights King for me to dismiss
this theory I think it would be
incredible if this was one of the big
reveals but it's just my opinion and you
can certainly disagree with me if you
want to regardless of how it ends I do
believe there is one more big secret
that lies within those crypts and I am
leaning towards us getting another big
reveal in the final episodes but let me
know what you think about any of this
down below in the comment section I have
to thank you all for watching this video
especially if you made it this far and I
hope you did otherwise most of what I
said will not make much sense but in my
opinion I believe the crypts have more
to do with the others in the night King
than any other Theory out there
considering how much evidence has been
put forth in the books Winterfell was
built immediately after the long night
ended and it was built by the same
person who built the wall I think this
is where the night King had fallen
during the war and he may have been
imprisoned in the crypts to ensure he
didn't get free again it would explain
why this location was chosen right over
the natural Hot Springs it would kind of
counteract the magic the night King has
over the ice and if he wasn't the crypts
it would also explain why they are
always so cold even with the hot water
rushing through the walls of the castle
maybe the Starks have other magic
besides warding that helps keep any of
the others imprisoned down there and
that's why a stark must always remain
there or it's just because a star can
stop the night king from taking over
Winterfell and freeing whatever is down
there and of course the Starks always
have dreams about the crypts and I think
Ned's dream may be very telling when he
says he saw the dead King staring back
at him with eyes of ice it makes a lot
of sense to me but maybe I am just crazy
let me know what you think though does
Winterfell
or it's crypts have any significance to
you and do you think they will serve any
purpose in the end put all your thoughts
questions and opinions down below thank
you for watching and thank you to all of
my patreon supporters I hope you all
have a great day I'll see you in the
next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you